what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are on our way today to go watch uh
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania but before
that I got hit up on social media a bunch
about these two King the Conqueror specific
trailers and I was like all right well this
is our last chance to watch it fresh because
it doesn't make sense to watch it after we've
already seen the movie so we're gonna watch
it right now with you guys so please go ahead
leave a like also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when our
review is up for uh admin and the WASP quantumia
right here on this very Channel speaking of which
in case you didn't catch the memo uh John
campia Christian harloff and I are teaming
up for a live event at Flappers comedy club
in Burbank California Sunday February 19th
we're gonna be doing like a huge talk about
Ant-Man and the wasp condominia and a bunch
of other things I mean not a last good time
get to meet a bunch of people it's gonna be
a great time plenty of uh you can if you want
to get a drink already let's get to it guys
you come from above
like him oh he will burn the world
to find you I wonder who that was
the Conqueror the Conqueror in the MCU we
knew we wanted to go to places no never been
I'm hitting Ant-Man against a major
villain felt perfect a version of
this character in the series
Loki yes very true this is wild
at the chair it's very different Kang is
an infinite number of different personas
goddamn right you need an actor to
be able to pull that off and that is
Jonathan Majors yeah he's very versatile
rewrite existence and shatter timelines
yes
banish me of time there's some details you told me
about how time plays within our relationship love
friendship Legacy Ant-Man versus King this is
it people are gonna lose their mind yeah whoa
reality League Ant-Man
oh small world after
the Conqueror he will burn the world to find him
on February 17th if you want to stop what's coming
gotta hurry I don't care who this guy is use that
shot for so many things Joy it's bad because it is
a shield whoa nice ant armies Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania ready PG-13 February 17th get tickets
now man I my mind was just kind of spinning there
with there's so much little nuggets of information
that the line that really stood out to me the
most was taking revenge on those who banished
him because I'm like that could mean a variety of
things on like because obviously he's trapped here
in the quantum realm and what it seems like this
is focused on because while we know like there's
going to be multiple King variants perhaps uh
maybe not in this film but in the King Dynasty or
as the course of phase five ultimately progresses
that there will be more kings that do show up but
based off of the marketing and everything that
they're saying about this specific King that he
is indeed the main villain he is indeed the king
that is the ultimate big bad threat or new Thanos
per se uh so especially if he's the one who's been
like banished at the quantum realm and I'm like
trying to have my own theories of what it could be
I mean some one implication of what that can mean
is it's like someone like Jenny van dying perhaps
is uh in contribution with others there who helped
trap him here because I knew how dangerous it
was to keep him out it could be referring to
the Council of kings and like he's just too bad we
gotta we gotta make sure he's he stays stuck here
um but yeah that was uh that was exceptional I
get why people wanted us to to watch this one
because this was the first trailer out of all
the marketing for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania we've heard all the hype about King the
Conqueror but this is you know an Avengers
Infinity War when you know Mark Ruffalo um comes
to the sanctum Santorum and he's like Thanos is
coming that's what this did for me yeah yeah
totally yeah and I think that I I mean I will
be excited to see various iterations of Kang
but I feel like this movie definitely would
want to focus directly in on this one because
most people saw Loki but I feel like the movies
probably reach a little bit higher in terms of
getting to everyone and I feel like here yeah
you would want to set the stage and really let
your new big bad you know conquer it you know
like command that presence before bringing in
other variants and stuff but I just love the
other glimpses we got him I loved the look like
you can really pick out some of the details on
the Wardrobe the costume and whatnot and also
just that further sense of who else lives under
the quantum like who else lives in the quantum
realm near chronopolis who is affected by Kang's
imprisonment here because you know they're stuck
in here with him to borrow that Watchman bit
um and yeah I mean part of me wonders you know I
mean he remains was definitely involved with that
so maybe we will get some further TVA involvements
because like whoever he remains set that up with I
could see being involved with trapping Kang here
uh or maybe even someone Fantastic Four related
given the lineage uh with Richard's family and
whatnot and maybe that could be at least a way to
hint at and tease the Fantastic Four without like
fully bringing them in and distracting everybody
with that um and part part of me kind of feels
like me maybe they will want to kind of keep
any outside Easter eggs or hints at the future
kind of at Bay because two this is a big Stakes
movie for Ant-Man they want this I think to be
the biggest and most you know important Ant-Man
movie so I feel like the less they can distract
from that the better perhaps yeah I think though
that they are really setting the stage here and
I think what Marvel's really wanting to implement
is guys everything that you were feeling about
Marvel phase four Ant-Man quantumania is very
much vital and it you will see how this film is
setting up the Kang Dynasty and of course Secret
Wars which is supposed to follow immediately after
that and you know glimpsing this trailer too it is
nice to get these teases because then one thing
that some people might not register about um King
the Conqueror is he he himself is not really a
super powered he's like super intelligent he's a
scientist and you know when you're seeing him use
powers here there are parts that were making me
kind of question a little bit because we've seen
in other trailers too where it looked like he had
like telekinesis abilities yeah which I'm like uh
I mean he could be just harnessing some energy it
looks like while he's been trapped here he has
found a wave with the like the beams that he has
to harness Quantum technology in order to create
a set of Weaponry for himself which I think think
is really neat but I feel like this movie is you
know we I feel like we often say this leading into
movies for Marvel and it's kept happening with
phase four of face this movie for phase four this
project for phase four is really going to be the
big thing that sets up the future the Multiverse
Song and all that and then a lot of times it
didn't end up feeling that way by by the end of it
I'm under the impression I'm gonna say it one more
time that this just seems like especially with the
fact it's getting the conquerors the villain that
this is super duper important for the trajectory
of however phase five ultimately unfolds and I'm
excited for it I think this trailer is great and
yeah Jonathan Majors is one versatile actor so to
see him uh be able to do multiple versions of Kang
I'm very much excited for because if there is an
actor out there who can pull it off it is Jonathan
Majors you know like my introduction to him was
Lovecraft country where he was like a super kind
of like he was a cool guy but it's almost like a
really nerdy guy yeah yeah yeah he was a very sort
of relatable character yeah whereas even just from
he who remains to seeing what he's been doing with
King the Conqueror with this the bits of footage
of this Conquest like Persona I feel like this
is already a very different interpretation and
it seems equally believable so yeah guys I'm
excited Ant-Man and the WASP quants Mania there's
gonna be plenty to talk about once this film is
actually out uh can't wait let me know when you
guys are gonna go watch it hopefully I can see
some of the lab event leave a like subscribe
before we go let's dance with the patreon
Brian pay my dude I just want to say hello to you
and to wish you a happy and very romantic February
all right you know we're here talking about the
quantum realm but if there's one thing that is
not tiny or minuscule or microscopic it's our love
for you and the love that you have shown us and I
want to take that love to the next level in this
month you know we should meet up you know maybe go
to a nice candlelit romantic dinner swap massages
tell each other's secrets and things giggle a lot
have a pillow fight something like that you
know maybe get uh into an altercation about
who gets to you know be with Greg even though
Greg's already married and it's not really a
point in even arguing about it but still it's the
principle that matters and you seem like a guy at
principal Brian so uh we're sending you the love
and uh you know hands off my man's but otherwise
keep on pledging and staying beautiful and
sexy and all that good stuff love you buddy